ladies and gentlemen we have a five-time
Oscar nominee in the house
hi Juliette more you've got an orange
frontrunner chair Thanks yes your chair
have a seat and you'll be able to see me
because my red dress I know a good thing
you're not sitting here I'm here with
Julianne Moore the star of still Alice
on Fandango frontrunner Julianne thanks
for being here thank you for having me
is there a moment that you think back to
earlier in your career as being a
pivotal moment oh my gosh yes I mean I
when I first started out in the business
I was on a soap opera and I did a lot of
theater off-broadway and regional and I
didn't have a film career at all not at
all and whatever I auditioned for I
never got and I thought that that was
just gonna be an avenue that wasn't open
to me and then everything changed with
independent film I mean it completely
changed suddenly Robert Altman saw me in
a production of Vanya Uncle Vanya that
production was made into a film by Louis
Malle and I read this script by Todd
Haynes called safe so I did those three
things kind of close together but what
really changed for me in terms of my
professional life was they all came out
in the same year Wow so I went from
having no film career and no possibility
of a film career to suddenly having
having this amazing opportunity and it
was really all due to independent film
and that's 20 years ago yeah and what's
interesting is that yes you've done the
Hannibal's and the Hunger Games and but
you've also really stayed true to the
other kind of movies the smaller movies
that you were very passionate about as
well I read so lucky I've worked with so
many amazing filmmakers do you try to do
it mathematically where it's kind of one
for me one for them one for me one for
them
I wish that I had that kind of control I
don't we don't you know we really can
only do what comes our way and the only
the only control an actor has is whether
or not you say yes or no you know so
when you see something you love you do
it no but but it's not that you have no
control over the budget or anything like
that so what did your theater or more
importantly what did your as the world
turns friends have to say when they saw
all of these indie films that you ended
up doing was actually a woman on that
show who told me about the
the audition actually she was the one
who said hey you know Andre Gregory is
doing this production Uncle Vanya and I
was like well didn't I called and tried
it you know so we were very it was kind
of a nice little collective we'll start
at the same time well speaking of great
independent films you're in one right
now called still Alice so I want to
watch a scene from this movie with you
and we're gonna pause it and discuss key
moments am i operating you cannot good
at this I'll do mostly be operating but
if something strikes you and you want to
talk about you let me know all right so
this is a really powerful scene with you
and Alec Baldwin who plays your husband
yeah
he's soaked times now this is a very
pivotal moment to me because this is the
moment where your character is finally
letting her family in alright these
fears that she has that she might have
early yes she's terrified and I think if
I weren't I love Alex so much and love
working with him and feel so comfortable
with him that I was I remember feeling
really really relaxed and really and it
felt very intimate and it was just it
was his tone to that idea that he kept
his eyes closed and it did it felt like
you were you know telling somebody
something in the mail at night okay well
let's see how it continues here I got
something
are you talking Beth I've been seeing a
neurologist I've been seeing the
neurologist why how would you describe
the mix of emotions that she's going
through right here you see them all on
her face she's like I said she's
terrified and and finally realizes that
it's not something that is gonna be
taken care of easily you know she's
she's someone who's very educated and
who's already diagnosed herself and said
oh I have a brain tumor and that must be
what it is but then it's slowly
realizing that it's something you know
the her cognitive decline is significant
and and so she's admitting to it herself
and she's afraid to tell him and I think
to there's that hope that maybe you're
wrong you know when you know that you're
probably right well let's see what his
reaction is yeah and I think that it may
be early onset Alzheimer's disease
hi I think that doesn't make any sense
at all I want to tell you because I
don't know anything for sure but I've
been doing all these tests did you find
in your research that that was a common
response from close family members when
the patient initially brings it up oh
this can't be true denial yeah I I think
often there's that and then and saying
you know you're oh that's not that's not
happening or people just ignoring it or
wanting it to go away and one of these
are suggesting to me about people who
are experienced in Alzheimer's diseases
they don't feel seen people don't want
to look at it it's too scary for them to
look at I think when a family member
does that it can feel like a real
rejection hmm well let's see how it
progresses here is completely insane I
was running on campus and while ago I
can't I can't remember appointments
words I think we all have memory lapses
that's a sign of getting old or the
other day I couldn't remember the word
drops out I look at your face here it's
just it's fear she's saying I'm you know
I need you I need the support you know
let's let's talk about this you know
you're he's her intellectual and
romantic partner so she's like okay okay
here now I can I can finally share my
burden yeah you know it takes a little
bit of a turn here yeah but there is no
diagnosis yeah okay well then I think
that this is ridiculous is complete
[ __ ] you don't have all why won't
you take me seriously
no I know what I'm feeling I know what
feeling and feels like my brain is
[ __ ] dying and everything I've worked
for in my entire life is going so is the
anger there at the situation of what
she's going through or is the anger that
he doesn't but seem to believe her thank
you that's interesting well it's it's a
couple of things the anger is about her
fear but it's also probably an old
saying it's probably an old thing in
their marriage like you know I tell you
this stuff and you never listen so it's
that kind of like old partnership thing
we're like
we've been through this before like that
last time if the car would start you
told me it was gonna start but it didn't
start it wasn't my fault so there's that
too
so the combination of something that has
happened it maybe exists in their
marriage is personal and maybe wouldn't
be as big an issue except for what she's
feeling at that moment all comes
together it's that confluence and this
is also the first time we've seen her
cry and maybe I think the only time in
the movie you really see her across
she's been holding it in yeah trying to
be brave yeah well the floodgates open
hey Alec was so great right because he's
cuz right away as soon as I start like
that he was a c'mere c'mere then hear
him go don't cry and in such a such a
lovely way and that's that thing that
happens in a relationship to where
people do know each other that way where
where when you do explode because of an
old thing the other partner might say
well okay we've been down this road
before and you know did you have all of
that emotion mapped out in your head or
did you let it take you where it would
take you each you don't have it mapped
out the great thing about film acting
the most exciting thing for me is that
you I want to put myself in a position
to have an emotional experience on
camera so I didn't know I was gonna cry
like that
I really didn't I didn't and I just knew
that what I had to do was tell him
something really important something
that was urgent you know was interesting
actually it was written that my
character got out of bed and stood
across the room and I said you know says
the directions I said I don't think she
would I so I think is I think I've seen
is really intimate that it's about just
like saying with somebody he doesn't
middle of night you know right Wow it's
one of the most powerful moments in the
film so I congratulate you on it and
thank you so much for telling us more
about it okay now if you have not seen
still Alice be sure to check it out and
thanks so much for watching
Fandango frontrunners - thank you for
joining us today we have made you your
very own Fandango gift card in character
as still Alice
hi there so just good yay have fun yeah
thanks again it breaks as you walk over
here to this iPad we're gonna take a
quick photo oh sure okay we'll put this
on your Twitter on the Twitter one two
three
love it thanks so much great to see you
guys